we decided to make a film I just talked
about like maybe like doing a film which
was a homage to like films i grew up
with which was some danger film I had
his buddy cross-cultural hybrid of when
I was going on there was lived in
Australia but we got like supper bingo
we got something the stage we also got a
lot of Japanese stuff so there's this
sort of like archetypal ninja movie
called shinobu kimono also a lot of
American and Japanese cheesy ninja belt
with probably nameless directors all
through the 80s American Ninja and a
bunch of other stuff so and then it
would be good to to an update of that
like give essentially what was a bichon
where the applications of an Asian I
make it into like a really cool stylized
film so that's what I'm services there
was this great guy who was in all the
70s and 80s ninja movies goggles sho
kosugi hi I'm Michelle consume it was
always like the the archetype of nimpah
so got him out of sort of
semi-retirement adhesive the film now is
like as the master or what a guy who
trains every
assassin ninja taisen comes out
Thanksgiving